and her five children arrived here in
Tripoli from Sudan three weeks ago they
fled the violence between the
paramilitary rapid support forces and
the Army in Sudan along with dozens of
other families they've been camped here
on the streets near the U.N Refugee
agency's registration Center ever since
we are really suffering my son was hit
by a car and needs medical treatment my
other son is deaf and he is sick I don't
know where my husband is the refugee
agency gave me assistance once but it's
not enough according to the UN since the
conflict broke out in Sudan in April
more than seven hundred thousand people
have fled the country
most of them have fled to chatter Egypt
but now some are arriving here in Libya
the U.N Refugee agency has more than 47
200 registered refugees and Asylum
seekers in Libya nearly 23 000 of them
are Sudanese Nationals
samya Abdullah is from elginena in West
Darfur she says hundreds of people were
killed in the city as they tried to flee
in June she and her children survived
but were separated from her husband
another
some people bring us food and water but
it's not enough for all the children we
suffered due to the fighting in our
country and we fled to Libya we went to
the UN for help but they kicked us out
our children need a safe environment the
International Organization for migration
says there are more than 130 000
Sudanese migrants already in Libya they
make up around 20 of the migrant
population Libya has been in Conflict
for more than a decade but has seen
relative calm since a ceasefire was
agreed in 2020 if the fighting continues
in neighboring Sudan many fear there
could possibly be an influx of refugees
and possibly Fighters Crossing into
Libya and that could complicate The
Fragile peace achieved here
Deputy ambassador to Libya
this is the result of War origin's
destruction war is a Bloodshed war is
pain these people need help from all of
us from a legal standpoint because they
are Asylum Seekers we cannot directly
approach them but our doors are open and
those who come to us we try to help as
much as we can
unhcr says Libya is not a safe place for
refugees and Asylum Seekers and that
they try to give assistance to those who
are the most vulnerable
but for the women and children here
that's just not enough Malik trainer Al
Jazeera Tripoli
foreign